the libertarian economist Walter
Williams was born in 1936 in a poor but
thriving section of Philadelphia that
was later torn apart by crime and
violence this is where we lived the
Richard Allen project in North
Philadelphia when Williams was a small
child his father deserted his family he
was raised by his mother who was a high
school dropout and the family spent time
on welfare I broke out of the North
Philadelphia ghetto nearly 30 years ago
and so did most of my friends drafted
into the peacetime army Williams
eventually earned a PhD from UCLA in the
late 1960s and he soon became a
sought-after researcher in public
intellectual his best-known book 1982's
the state against blacks argues that a
major cause of black unemployment is
government intervention in the labor
market it is morally outrageous for
government to be cutting off the
ambitions of those trying to climb the
middle rungs of the economic ladder
you're saying that you can solve the
problems in Bank Williams contrarian
views have had wide exposure through
documentaries public appearances and for
the past 30 years a syndicated weekly
column that appears in about 140
newspapers throughout his career
Williams has used his personal
experiences to illustrate his ideas I
used to work in a store like this back
in those days just about any kid who
looked for a job could find one today in
ghettos like I grew up in 70% of black
children who looked for jobs cannot find
them his new book up from the projects
an autobiography is a fascinating look
at his childhood his half-century long
marriage to his recently departed wife
his unusual career path and the genesis
of his views on race economics and
politics reason TV spoke with Williams
an emeritus trustee of the reason
Foundation at his office at Virginia's
George Mason University Walter thanks
for talking to thank you you were
growing up in Philadelphia you spend
time on welfare you were raised in a
single-parent household how does where
you're from show up in where you are now
well I'm not sure I
as a youngster I never even thought
about being a college professor or
libertarian I was always a a radical
troublemaker a person who questioned the
the status quo
so the my upbringing might have had very
little to do with where I am now and
matter of fact even though we grew up
poor we didn't we didn't consider
ourselves poor that as a matter of fact
during those days to call somebody poor
was an insult or even to what to being
called poor mean that well it meant that
well you didn't eat or you you you miss
meals or you wore tattered clothes and
and all those weren't the case with me
but at least in neighborhoods where I
grew up in poor black neighborhoods
today there is kind of what I call
spiritual poverty that is poverty of the
Spirit and back when I was a kid my
mother used to always say to us she says
you know we have a beer pocketbook but
we have champagne tastes meaning that we
had high aspirations so where does the
spiritual poverty or where does the
aspirational poverty come from well if
you look at some of the characteristics
particularly of black people but it
applies to large extent everybody back
when I was coming up that is for a girl
to have a baby out of wedlock it was a
disgrace today women have babies out of
wedlock and they have a baby showers and
snow is no longer a disgrace and indeed
the legitimacy rate among blacks is
somewhere around 70% and back in the 40s
there couldn't have been more than 13 12
percent something like that or the
breakdown in the black family only 35
percent of kids black kids live in to
ground two-parent families and matter of
fact when we were coming up by my father
deserted us when I was three and my
sisters - and my they ultimately got
divorced and night in the late 40s but
but among our kid among our friends we
were the only kids in the Richard on
housing project that did not have a
mother and father in the house and and
today would be exactly the opposite
would be rare to have a mother and
father in the
in the household today in 2008 you wrote
that Obama's election and I'm quoting
here might turn our attention away from
the false notion that discrimination
explains the problems of a large segment
of the black community it has that
happened I don't see didn't as meant
very much for the black community I
don't see any big change I don't see
lower crime rates I don't see how more
greater high school graduation rates and
and but in general I I don't think that
there is much progress that blacks can
make through the political arena and
what do you mean by that because this is
you know I think most people most
observers whether the black or white or
you know European whatever would say
that you know that a lot of black
progress has been because of civil
rights act because of changes in Dasia
race so you look if you ask the question
you look at our country and you ask
question in what cities do blacks have
the highest crime suffer from the
highest victimized victimization rates
from crime the the the rottenness
schools the fervor poor living
conditions they are in the very cities
where a black is the mayor a black is
Chief of Police a black is the
superintendent of schools now I'm not
stating a causal relationship but I'm
saying that if political power meant so
much you would expect let's in a city
like Philadelphia where a black is the
mayor of black of super land school
black chief police you expect every
living conditons be wonderful and but
and on the other hand if you look at the
other end of another group of people
let's say Chinese and Japanese they
don't have any political power even in
the places such on the west coast where
they're the most murders sure the
Chinese have much political power in
China that's well at least in United
States but however according to
statistics Japanese or Chinese are in on
any measure of socioeconomic success
they're at the very top and and matter
of fact if you look into our history of
our country
the Irish had the greatest political
power and but they're the slowest rising
of any of the white ethnics ethnic
groups in our country so I think it's
false to assume that the economic power
depends on political power and you can
just go all around the world my
colleague Tom Saul has done extensive
work on the you know the Armenians in
the post Ottoman Empire they didn't have
any political power they were
discriminated against but high as
income-earning people Jews as well
throughout various subsets yeah the
challenge of Southeast Asia if it's not
political power that will help advance
living standards and quality of life how
do you I mean it's economic power that
right you have to develop skills and
training and the one of the reasons why
people make low wages is for the most
part they have low skills but but but
the getting rigged in a getting hold of
the political system or or even
eliminating every vestige of
discrimination is not very important for
economic advancement I mean if you look
at the question at one time there were
no blacks in the in the in the
professional basketball today blacks are
80 80 percent of professional basketball
players 60-some percent of professional
football players and it wasn't any
Fuhrman of affirmative action it wasn't
any court suits it wasn't getting rid of
discrimination what was it it was that
these guys and guests threw a 360 slam
dunk in your face and you can't do
anything about it but it's high skills
but it was a non doing of discrimination
right I mean when you think about a
football and basketballs color lines are
less kind of celebrated than Jackie
Robinson breaking into major league
baseball but there was a de facto law
against letting Black's play well the
best engines of it in terms of that in
terms of baseball it wasn't any
affirmative action it wasn't any court
suits it was the fact that there is a
huge huge pool of high skills in the
Negro what they call the Negro Leagues
that just could not be ignored and once
the Dodgers cracked it everybody else
had to go
along they just could not ignore this
huge pool of black talent what you would
agree and it would be the same thing if
this black talent were in physics
whereas in chemistry you just could not
ignore it what are the best ways to
speed up the process by which race or
ethnicity or social standing doesn't
matter in fields that should be
determined by merit well if it's not
lost well personally one of my strong
values is freedom of association and
when if you believe in freedom of
association you have to accept that
people will associate in ways that you
find offensive and I believe people have
the right to discriminate on any basis
they want so long as they're not using a
government so long as they're not using
you know for example I would disagree
that a library which should be able to
engage in racial discrimination against
me because I'm a taxpayer so a public
library a private library hive library
had the David Duke Memorial Library they
can keep I have no problem whatsoever
and and see discrimination is is
actually for me discrimination is just
simply an act of choice and we all
discriminate when when as I tell people
that when I was choosing a wife to marry
I didn't give every woman in Equal
Opportunity I discriminated against
Japanese women Italian women women with
criminal records women that did not rip
bathe regularly i discriminated at all
did you also you discriminated against
women who refused to return your phone
calls I assume well they we didn't have
a telephone but but what but no but the
point is is that that people have the
right in my opinion to associate in any
ways they want but however they should
not get subsidized now there's a whole
lot of laws on the books that subsidizes
discrimination that for example the
minimum wage law that subsidizes
engaging in written in the book you also
talk about when you were drafted into
the Army and you ended up going of
Georgia for an assignment that was the
first time that you met up with a Dasia
race segregation
in the deep south and you mentioned
going through bus stations and whatnot
where there were you know colored only
restrooms black only restrooms
restaurants etc what is the best and
most efficacious way to break down
state-sponsored discrimination well you
do it by the law because I think that
states do it states should not be able
to engage in discrimination and you you
do it by any means any means it's
necessary and to get rid of
state-sponsored discrimination and
including just disobeying the law and I
think that one of the things the very
fact that you do find state-sponsored
discrimination is good evidence that
that may be a discrimination would not
exist that is if you see a law on the
books well the reason why that law is on
the books is because not everyone would
behave according to specifications of
the law and so if you say well if you
see a law saying well blacks have to be
had to sit in the back of the trolley
car well you say well why do you need a
law if if the prolly cars are privately
owned that's what they were when the
discrimination started in our country
well the end by private car street car
companies would not discriminate against
the customers so the people who want a
discrimination won't need it at all so
where does that bring you in terms of a
variety of the civil rights acts that
were passed in the late 50s through the
mid 60s were those good laws where the
Civil Rights Acts good and necessary
ways of breaking down no no I think
civil rights act was a major error that
is during the 1960s when we had the
civil rights movement I think all that
we needed it was the law that said that
the Constitution of the United States
applies to each and every citizen in our
country as opposed to making a Civil
Rights Act as you know as in fact did
you know you mentioned in the book that
of both when you were hired as an
economist at Temple and then again at
George Mason that you sat down with your
the people who were hiring you said hey
if you're practicing affirmative action
I don't want any part of this what were
you a beneficiary of affirmative action
and if so you know how did you deal with
that when you found out about it
what was the effect of that on you well
I I understand at Temple University I
did not run into the problem but at
George Mason University I think after
I'd been here quite a while thee and the
the former chairman who hired me he said
that he got good he get beneficial
points from hiring me and Karen Vaughan
my colleague who's a woman and and later
on Karen Wong who was here before I was
she told me that that if a bill Snavely
bill Snavely was practicing permit of
action they weren't he what he didn't
get the right kind of black is a
tiresome to talk about yourself as the
libertarian black ya know I look at
people I don't see colors I don't judge
people by colors I say that well J your
your man just like I am and and and
whatever whatever you are after that
that's what my stuff all these to say he
says every man stands up to piss and
he's whatever he is after that do
colleges so practice affirmative action
for racial admissions and should that
stop well I think I think it definitely
should stop and and and most called oh
yes most colleges do increasingly there
are reports that affirmative action is
being practiced spring men into campuses
because women tend to do better on SATs
is that equally bad well I think that if
it is a private university private
universities would have the right to do
in my opinion they have the right to do
anything they want in terms of a
admitting students public universities I
think they ought to be constrained by
the law that they just cannot engage in
any kind of a what about private schools
that are so heavily subsidized either by
federal research dollars student loans I
mean then borrow then they are in effect
the government schools right right
and so and and if they're heavily
subsidized and which I first thing I
would do I'd get rid of the subsidizing
and then let them behave any way they
want to in the book you said that people
like Jackie Robinson and Wilt
Chamberlain had made it safe for the NBA
a major league baseball to hire
incompetent blacks such as you so that
you could now pursue a career in
baseball or basketball jay-z said what
what what I meant
by that example I was telling a group of
students and it was indeed a Templar
University and I was saying that I would
love the teacher course in physics I
love subatomic physics but I was saying
that black people cannot afford for me
to be teaching a course in in physics
and I was saying that I was getting an
example of basketball that in baseball
because of the excellence that of Jackie
Robinson or Wilt Chamberlain and Bill
Russell that I can now go play
basketball and I can mess up royally and
there's not a person in the audience can
say those blacks can't pay blast
basketball that is in that sense I meant
that black that black people can afford
incompetent basketball players but they
cannot afford afford incompetent physics
teachers now do you think and that's and
the same thing applies to I wrote a
column about about Obama that is a black
people I said I don't think that they
can afford for the first black president
to be a failure and he has every
indication of being a failure like the
Carter Administration well but do you
think I guess that's the broader point
is that between 1954 and now race
relations have clearly changed and most
of the most odious obvious
skree senses of racism are gone are we
past race or will we ever be password
has passed it yet yeah that is a you
know I think we've come a Americans have
come the furthest distance among any
group of people in solving the problems
of race in our country but we're not
past that that is if for example I was I
was saying in the book that I teach
tower
I teach PhD microeconomic theory and at
Temple University I hadn't detected at
George Mason University better Temple
University I the white students who are
most of students in the ph.d program at
the beginning of the semester asked me
hard questions things like this there
they were really testing my credentials
and so they you know check and see well
how was the firm ative action higher you
know and then after they after I just
calmly answered their questions they
said well they better learn some
economics so so that in the sense that
in that sense in terms of pride of a
people I think that black people just
kind of afford incompetence and in many
in most areas right still yeah let's
talk a little bit about the your
experience in the Academy you went to
UCLA in the mid to late 60s you worked
with people like James Buchanan and arm
and algae and what was it like to be at
a place like UCLA then this was a hotbed
not simply of you know I mean it was the
American dream to be in California in
the 60s but also from a libertarian
point of view this was a powerhouse
Department for free market ideas well I
as I said in the book I I did not know
that I was anything about UCLA when I
went to enter there and I didn't know
that is one of the top 10 economics
departments in the country and I was in
well over my head and there and these
are some of the top professors in
economics in the world and and I
benefited immensely from going to
attending UCLA but however it was quite
a challenge for me how much did that
form your ideology or your you know kind
of political thought well I think it
awakened me in something had always been
I've always been a radical I've always
challenged the status quo and but
however I did come out you know I
supported things like minimum wage laws
because I thought it was a good idea
until I ran some professors say well
look Walter let's look at the effects of
the minimum wage law as opposed to
looking at the intention they gave me
material to read and and I changed my
mind but I think that my free market
ideas I got polished at UCLA and being
exposed to some of the greatest
economists in the world do you think
that you've benefited from having a kind
of roundabout route to studying
economics as opposed to you know being a
whiz kid and you know graduating high
school when you're 13 and they go
directly to college and a PhD if I go
into college right after high school it
would have been an unmitigated disaster
I was further immature country as well
as the as well as you me yet at least to
me I was just unprepared to make kind of
make the sacrifices necessary and I
think many times that's that's true with
a many people today that is a
I'm very sure if I had to do it again I
tell my wife that it went with my
daughter she went out to 17 years old
and she went right into college in first
year or so was a disaster and I said if
we had to do it again I would would have
gotten her a job at McDonald's or at a
car wash for a couple days to let you
know a couple of years to let some
maturity set in
so maybe gaining some maturity you know
by a year or two outside of a education
and then go to college and then but more
importantly pay your own way what you've
been able to go to college I mean you
mentioned quite often that how heavily
subsidized and particularly in the 60s
and 70s I mean the UC system Cal States
has some very subsidizes effectively
free education wasn't that a good thing
though even if it's coming from the
state and even if it's being
expropriated from taxpayers no it's not
a good thing no it's not a good I just
would you have been able to go to
college otherwise uh
I might not even know a lot of the
incentive for my wife neide to move from
Philadelphia to Los Angels in 1961 was
that I no way in the world I could
afford to go to Temple University Temple
University was cheapest school and city
and I think was like $2,000 a year to go
there and I went to Cal State LA and it
was 125 dollars a year I believe was a
year there and so I got a highly subject
except highly subsidized education and I
don't know whether I would have gotten
an education but still that because I
got an education it doesn't mean that it
was a good idea to rip off the
California taxpayers well do you think
it a cost-benefit analysis if you take
yourself and everybody else who went
through Cal State and the costs
associated with that
and then the payback because you
certainly have paid a lot more back in
taxes than the you know of what would it
be about 400 bucks 500 bucks for four
years of Cal State at 125 and not to the
California taxpayers okay all right when
I go when I finish rip them off I left
the but however but I mean but is that I
mean is it a fair question from a
libertarian point of view we all want to
say you know whatever
nothing should be taken from the
taxpayer except very small pots of money
that go to clear public goods and
education doesn't meet that test so but
you know then again like you know we're
sitting you're working at George Mason
you worked at Temple these are state
universities you know is it such a bad
thing
well well if yeah I could have just as
soon I gone to Cal State or UCLA and
they and they charge a tuition of five
thousand a year five thousand dollars a
year and I could have gone out and
robbed somebody and got the five
thousand dollars so you wouldn't like
make the argument that well gee Williams
robbed the guy to get five thousand
dollars and you're going to pay it back
and you know later on in life you know
by higher taxes or whatever but the
solution to the problem is that we need
to do something with the with the
financial markets to enable people to be
able to get a loan to be able to go to
college and then of course pay it back
George Mason has become a very
well-known hotbed of libertarian Liz a
fair economic history from a free market
perspective from a libertarian
perspective how did that happen how did
you go from helping to build George
Mason's academic reputation from kind of
so-so to really moving it up a few
notches well I I think all the
responsibility is not mine I share with
my my colleagues but I became a chairman
in 1995 and I was chairman from 1995
until 2001 when Buckhannon won the Nobel
Prize in 1986 we had 26 faculty members
and when I became chairman we had 18
there was considerable hostility towards
our department and I tried to you know
to work with the administration to
rehire those people and I had a lot of
difficulty and so I just said well the
only way I'm going to improve the
department is to try to privatize the
department actually go out and raise
money to to be able do things with the
fact to be able to make hire and you
have to hire people and to subsidize
hiring people and so a lot of it was
with the generosity of supporters out
there
the lily endowment and Olin foundation
the old and Foundation this is I mean so
you brought in a new revenue stream but
you lost a lot on it yeah yeah um a lot
of people in the Academy and from
outside circa this is a kind of
corporate takeover of the university and
of the Academy and the would not orbit a
coup well yeah I mean talk about that
how did you secure academic freedom for
your research faculty well I think that
the the people who who gave me money and
a lot of was just your private donations
other people gave money they just they
they respected me and my ambitions and
my vision and I had complete say-so over
how the money would be spent and so they
explains the gold fixtures in the men's
room here not a date I wish I did but
but they had they had no say-so in how
the money would be spent and then also
towards the end of my tenure as chairman
the my my colleagues actually very
successful in raising money were able to
hire Vernon Smith and and mattify his
crew from Arizona and bring all six or
seven seven I think here and he was here
for a year and a half and he won Nobel
Prize you guys time that perfectly Yeah
right but let's talk a bit about the
broad-based libertarian movement do you
do you feel that you're part of a
libertarian movement no I don't know so
what are you that well I'm not a part of
a movement I've never been a part of
movement I just I just do my own thing
can we tally up a score and say are we
more free are we less free are we moving
in the right direction are you happy
about the world that your daughter is
inheriting and that year no no I
grandchildren I think for the first time
first time in our history it's prudent
for parents to tell their children to
have enough gold and silver coins than
enough to be able to get out of this
country and and
moved somewhere else' well somewhere
else think you know now me and it does
make any difference I mean for example
Jews in Austria I mean they should have
had enough money to get out and didn't
make any difference where they moved you
know so the point is is that for the
first time in our history a people are
considering leaving you Knights are
taking their wealth out of the United
States we're all before United States
was the bastion of Liberty and then low
regulations and people are bringing
their wealth to our country so I think
that we have to be concerned what I'm
losing our liberties what needs to
happen for that to reverse I mean and
it's one thing to say oK we've got a
reduced regulation but what are what are
the kind of policy steps and the kind of
psychological or ideological steps that
need to happen I don't think I don't
think anything is going to happen I
think what I think what one has to ask
himself is uh are we so arrogant as
American people to think that we are
different from other people around the
world that is do we are how different
are we from the Romans went down the
tubes or the British or the French or
the or the Spanish or the Portuguese
these are these are great empires of the
past but they went down the tubes for
roughly the same things that we're doing
liberty is the rare state of affairs in
mankind's history arbitrary abuse and
control by others is the standard dish
even now and all the tendencies are is
for us to lose have greater and greater
amounts of our Liberty usurped by a
government if you press me for a trend
in the opposite direction because of the
the Obama administration the Democrat
control of the house and the Senate they
become become so bold in many of their
actions that for the first time in my
life
Americans are debating about the
Constitution with people forming a Tea
Party movement and all this kind of
fervor that I've never heard before in
my 75 years of life but is that enough
or is it too late
and I'm not sure Walter Williams thank
you very much for talking with us and
for all of your writing and especially
your new book up from the projects in
autobiography okay